[Music]
welcome to your biscuits I'm Linc and
I'm Rhett joining us today at the round
table of dim lighting our Sam Gorski and
Niko / Inger the founding directors and
visual effects masterminds behind a
popular YouTube channel corridor digital
corridor digital delivers a unique and
impressive style to the digital media
space producing high-quality science
fiction and video game inspired shorts
often on tight budgets the visual
effects in their videos are some of the
best on YouTube yes right I should it's
some of the best on YouTube and in the
past 5 why don't you just say the best
on YouTube link okay I'll say it
they're the best on you Oh what I don't
know we also had pretty long on this
shirt yeah this is Freddy W vs. corridor
digital they're all friends and they're
all great guys come on and collaborators
yes they are but corridors is it was
great let's just focus on them yeah in
the past five years they've gained over
three million subscribers and 300
million views they're also helping to
redefine sci-fi because they're bringing
a lot of comedy to their videos like
minecraft the last minecart which has
over 30 million views are Superman with
a GoPro which has over 16 million views
you can see these are more than just
cool sci-fi videos there's a
light-hearted and comical tone beneath
all of this stimulating visual effects
which really resonates with the Internet
audience another example is the video
called superheroes versus game heroes
with over two million views and climbing
can you guess what that one's about
superheroes vs. video game heroes that's
what it's about
oh thanks for clarifying so you got Thor
facing off against Steve from minecraft
great video I play a clip for you but
it's so much about the visual you pretty
much have to go to their channel to
experience how talented these guys
really and you should do that
after you listen to this biscuit where
we talked to Sammy Nico about how they
met and bonded over Star Wars what
inspired that Superman with the GoPro
video and how they get away with using
drones and a lot of the videos they film
the new series they directed exclusively
on snapchat called snapper hero and how
they deal with arguments because we can
learn something from this
on set by using a brilliant concept they
invented called the wild card oh yeah
okay so we'll get into all that but
first we want to mention our sponsor EF
College Break they make travel easy
affordable and even more fun for anyone
ages 18 to 28 college not required
traveling around the world you know this
it's one of the most exciting things you
can do especially when you're young
before you get old and things begin to
creak that hasn't that hasn't happened
to us yet but your life gets busy and
you're young you should take advantage
of that time but you got to plan and
that's the most you can get bogged down
in those details of planning you got to
spend hours on the internet searching
for flights and hotels you got to figure
out what to do when to do it you got to
figure out how to get between cities get
it tickets for sites in advance dealing
with cancellations and closures and
delays you get the idea
I mean to me this is like the biggest
source of anxiety around trips is
questioning whether I've adequately
planned I mean right before I go you
know I'm like well you know I I go to
all these different websites I try to
figure it out and I just pack underwear
well now I get overwhelmed and I don't I
don't plan anything I don't do anything
and then if I do plan something then I'm
like what have I forgotten and then I
get there and I'm like what would I be
doing if I knew what I should be doing
like what am i bad place to be what am I
missing and and if there's people with
me they're like and I'm the guy who made
the decision you're a loser
scrutinized constantly for the decisions
I may hate you for the rest of their
lives
let AFUE college break and their expert
travelers take care of all this for you
booking flights lodging transportation
while you're there site and event
coordination and here's the trump card
they provide you with a tour director
who's a local expert so you can blame
that guy yeah there's nothing to blame
because it's all gonna work out they
build group trips across six continents
with everything from road tripping
through Europe cruising the islands of
Thailand taking a grand tour of Italy I
mean you got to go to the site in not
only will you have amazing experience in
these new places all around the world
but you're gonna meet new people make
lifelong friends because that's how it
works you sign up you don't even have to
sign up with anybody else you can sign
up so
hello but you know what there's gonna be
other people on the trip you're gonna
meet the love of your life but asterisks
is Rhett said that they didn't say that
this is not a romance thing I just like
to think of traveling around the world
and you know falling in love because
that's how I met my wife on a on a boat
in Venice not true not true I met her in
Fuquay Varina but it's focused on the
travel kiss on romance bottom line is it
doesn't have to be intimidating to plan
a trip outside of the country an EF
college Break makes it possible okay I'm
on the site right now and on top of them
amazing trips they've already set up for
this year like Oktoberfest in Germany
they're already planning trips for next
year as well you should look into those
here's what a highlights of Australia's
coast how about an escapade through
London and Scotland how about it the
world is out there people and it's
waiting to be explored and you ain't
even got to plan it head over to our
special URL EF college break comm slash
rhett and Link and we will hook you up
with an extra $100 off your next
adventure that's right $100 off EF
College break.com slash rhett and Link
now onto the biscuit let's step through
a few of your recent videos we'll start
with a favorite one which isn't quite as
recent but Superman with a GoPro oh yeah
so I mean this is this is amazing it
performed extremely well you've got
Superman strapping on the GoPro on his
head and then taking you know you taking
me what was it that was it had it had
your name on it
he had like a lost GoPro and he put it
on his head and flew around ah yes he
took it off his head at the end give it
back and this was right right around the
time when you started seeing people use
drones and yeah in their videos and
who's gonna do the next cool thing and
you guys sort of took it up a few
notches yeah so what's the genesis of
the idea for you and then we'll talk a
little bit about the execution of it
well yeah Brandon was for those of well
for those out there who are unaware the
Freddy W channel needs to be Freddie
Wong and Brandon Laatsch and Brandon is
still in the same building that we are
so will frequently work together and do
stuff together every we were on a gaming
show too
but there is he need to shoot this short
little video where he was like on the
roof of our building and like Christmas
presents are like shooting on his butt
or something like that I can't quite
remember the details anyways and he did
an aerial that was it that was pretty
detailed yah i remember picturing like
that christmas presents coming out of
Brandon's but that's as detailed as I
want to get I'm pretty sure it's
something like that like he flew away
using like Christmas present sizes
propulsion ok yeah yeah but so we were
getting this aerial shot with the drone
and it you know just dream like a crane
you just flowering it over the thing you
know over Brandon and we're done and I'm
like cool and I just you know crank the
throttle decided to fly it around a
little bit because we were out there the
Sun was setting it was pretty and as I
like floored it and like just started
kind of having fun like thought occurred
to me like man this is you know it's
really cool it's like a flying I mean
it's whatever the biggest revelation in
the world the things were flying at
GoPro on the on the on the drone at the
time roxette's camera that it carried
and so I got to kind of thing like you
look at GoPros like you know sports
footage you wear the GoPro and you fly a
mic on you could maybe do something with
like wearing a GoPro and flying so
that's kind of how it started
um and then from there like we like Sam
and I were talking coming up with
different ideas you know do you just so
he pops a GoPro on their head they start
flying what else can you do I guess you
get green screen some arms in front and
you know make it look a little more
natural like you're actually you know
filming with it um you can do some
visual effects and new transitions like
somebody's running on the ground and
they leap and then you know transitions
to drone footage I think we did a test
like that we're just running on the
ground and just pretended to do a little
hop and then transition to drone footage
and it worked flawlessly because and
that's just a cut like a cut any edit
pretty much know like wish panty or yeah
there's like a little bit of tweak and
sometimes you know just the blended
shots but not too minimal I think it's
the GoPro is like it's shaky it has this
natural shake and that shake is perfect
for like breaking your visual
concentration for like that brief moment
at a yeah so you just you just flew the
drone in approximately the same place
that you just shot that the guy with the
GoPro on its head just like jump exactly
approximated his height and then jump
off yep from there
exactly and so we were kind of working
from there like so we hit a solid idea
you know it's really cool visual I
wondered if he even still have that old
video clip on our phones like you
remember you posted on Vimeo or
something like that
we're just experimenting and are shown
to everybody just blowing their mind
like this you know say I'm just running
and then something like jumping up in
the air and you know flying up really
high and then the next thing that we did
is you know start thinking about like
how can we make this into a real video
concept outside of just I'm a dude
flying and when it comes to youtube it's
thankfully this land of like loose IP
management we decided to pick a
character that every simillar with which
was Superman um you know Superman can
fly and Superman with a GoPro sounds
like a pretty interesting video that
you'd want to watch but it doesn't just
quite end right there because you could
throw a GoPro on Superman's head you can
fly around and that's neat and it's cool
and it's you know I'm sure some people
would share it but it's always nice to
just get a little bit of that storyline
in there a little bit that true line to
like put that button on the package and
that's when Sam came up with the whole
idea of like Oh a lost GoPro want I just
get some sweet shots while I go deliver
it to its its owner right because why
else would Superman be you know flying
around with a GoPro exactly yeah and
then but can you fly a drone over Dodger
Stadium legally I don't know we didn't
actually shoot that shot at the time we
were working with a friend Taylor
shin taylor chin yeah that guy's a total
baller
he owns the site him under the bus like
site called like drone fly comm and he's
like he's basically wonder he's a drone
pilot and like this guy who runs the
site and basically we'd worked with him
a few times in the past and basically he
does like training sessions for people
and so a couple shots in that video
we're like him out in like training
sessions and just filming crazy stuff
and then he sends it back to us and we
just put the green-screen arms over it
right so like going over the observatory
that kind of thing the reserva Tori was
us oh it really was yeah yeah yeah it's
a little bit of a mix here and there
yeah the shots of Taylor did that he did
by himself was a Dodger Stadium he's
actually he was showing
drones to firefighters so they could use
it to look at like burning buildings or
something like that or forest fire yeah
because there's like a training facility
out by Dodger Stadium and so since he's
right by there like we would want to get
this you know some landmark shots so he
just went and got the stadium shot he
also did one we just like flying around
I think Sherman Oaks which is like near
the end of Superman's flying back - yeah
he basically did all the complicated
shots in that piece but it's pretty
easily what's legal oh boy yeah we've
been talking about this it's first yeah
I try to figure it out right yeah I mean
you've got drone shots in everything
everything is please I mean it's it's
this Superman video we did has been
honestly one of the like the most like
the biggest videos we've released not
only because it was the fastest growing
but the way it's affected like our
relationships and networks between like
other companies and interviews and just
like all these like things and
opportunities have actually come out of
it just really cool like you know last
year and this year at NAB we've like
been doing like professional panels
there and we won this like the New York
City drone Film Festival with that that
video and and we just did an interview -
with the Wall Street Journal recently
where this this drone grey area came up
yeah and yeah it's it there's no clear
there's no actual definitive answer on
anything right now
because there weren't any rules to begin
with like when he shot Superman with a
GoPro there was like no regulator
there's no rules and then FAA said you
know what no commercial flying until we
make rules at which point everybody who
was doing flying for video and film and
real estate was like my invoice now says
graphic design instead of drone flying
yeah you get the sense you know even
that shot especially because the stadium
is empty at the time you get the the
sense that you're seeing something that
you're not supposed to see and I mean I
think it's I think there's a story about
this recently and it just makes sense
that this is gonna start happening more
and more
just okay hey there's a celebrity that
I'm a fan of I can I know where they
live I'm just gonna fly drawn into their
backyard yeah and go right into the open
backdoor I mean like that's so it's
so easy to do right the problem is
getting it back when they shut the back
door we just fly over the pool you know
it's true and you know I think that's to
the credit of the community out there of
drone pilots is that you really haven't
heard any horror stories yet you haven't
heard of anybody really getting too
injured or things like you know flying a
drone into a celebrity's backyard or
something that are looking through the
bedroom window it only takes one it does
only takes one South Park episode though
no
the drone one mmm okay well it's just
what you mentioned they're flying it
into a backyard and up to someone's
windows that's what the episodes about
you should you should check it out
because that's the first thing that you
think about I mean let's talk about
another one the ghillie suit man I don't
even know if that's how you say it yeah
I didn't know if you tell me what a
ghillie suit was you know I don't know
and I'm from North Carolina where
there's plenty of hunters but when I saw
it oh it's a it's the suit that like
hunters wear it's basically like a
walking duck blind yeah for it for
hunting any blending in yep do you have
experience with that Kim with was just
like somebody had one year like oh well
we got to do something we decided to get
one for that project specifically yeah
play a lot of video games and if you
play a lot of first-person shooters
you're pretty familiar with the concept
like a ghillie suit yes it's like the
ultimate sniper camouflage the funny
thing like that video is actually more
of a has more of a story with us to do
as like a studio and growing as a
production company because over the past
year we've actually ran a patreon
campaign yes we were you know it's
crowdfunded crowdfunding for our videos
and this is only for our videos that
aren't sponsored so let's just you know
get a little crazier and actually like
you know pay our crew and that kind of
stuff we're just doing a you know simple
video it's not you know not supported by
anything other than ad revenue all right
so people pledge a monthly contribution
$1 $10 you can do monthly or you can do
by video and so we actually do it by
video I've done in return we offer like
rewards for those videos like we'll
actually at a certain tier we give
people to all the After Effects files
for our effects shots so they can just
see how we did all our effects but the
ghillie suit video is actually for those
who don't know we have another like a
third
a guy in corridor digital in his name is
Jake Watson and he's our producer and he
helps put together all the shoots and
helps you know we're all trying to run
the business and he helps with that as
well and then we have another kind of
team that's expanding we have Ren Ren
Waichman who runs the YouTube channel
rend the Reaper he's done a lot of his
own stuff that's really cool but he's
kind of working with us full-time now
along with a couple of people here and
there but the ghillie suit was actually
Jake going out and wanting to put a
piece together because you know Sam and
I are getting to do all the fun stuff
and direct and cope with all his ideas
so Jake sitting there like yeah we
weren't actually on set for any of that
okay yeah and and that's actually been
kind of this thing we we're trying to
figure out how to do these days because
we have so many talented people we work
with and there's only so many you know
projects we can be involved with at one
time so it's basically the last few
months in combination also with you know
working with people on patreon is is
this opportunity for other people to
come in and have their ideas made and
they can direct and you know we still
have that channel to post things on and
so so your patreon account you basically
I mean as of looking today it's like
right around five grand per video yeah
so you said to Jake hey all right here's
five grand make that one pretty amore
take pretty much like you were - yeah
and to be fair like when it comes to
patreon the actual number of dollars you
get is usually about 75% of what you
actually see okay I'm just because
that's like what's pledged but what
people actually would you actually get
when you run credit cards and the time
comes different but yeah but yeah so
that was a chance for like you know for
Jake to go out and actually hire a
camera guy who's you know a friend that
we've worked at the ton but you know
hire a guy who could come out and shoot
it who's talented that actor is hired
you know I get it so I mean it
represents you guys growing from just
being a two-man outfit or I know you've
been working in certainly collaborating
with many people over the years and have
people that you work with actually hire
but taking that next step but yeah you
know that it still fits your the tone of
your brand that you know that is okay
you've got it's it's the brand is a mix
of special effects and action and
mm-hmm you know I've found it
interesting that that was that was more
I mean it had some special effects in it
you know a guy got shot
check check the box right up but it's
you know it's much more of a comedic
video hmm but but there's a but there's
elements of comedy and pretty much I
would say every single one but most of
the videos you do that's a part of your
is that something that when you think
about your brand is it that defined that
well we're gonna we're gonna take the
committee cake on this or is that
because it gets more views how does I
mean honestly if when it comes to making
a video three minutes long or four
minutes long or five I mean making
things funny light-hearted is I feel
like the key to success on online videos
because like to really snap somebody
into like a serious like you know
perspective when they're watching some
it it takes I think a little bit more
like immersion then online video can
offer you know you're watching something
on your phone it's like how quickly are
you gonna get like seriously emotionally
invested in something that's very
serious like it's it's harder to do that
on a to three-minute scale so we've kind
of like tried to find that way to you
know avoid I guess avoid like
accidentally like making something super
serious and then a comes off really
goofy and known gets it it's like you
know it's it's in the interest of
keeping things fun and entertaining and
not slowing things down to how'd you
how'd you discover that or is it just an
instinct ah it's more of an instinct I
feel like I mean because you know it's
like we love really cool serious movies
and like David Fincher is one of my
favorite directors and most of this
stuff is like you know 90% serious right
but you know I feel like as YouTube
creators and also our personalities too
it's like when you're making video game
inspired stuff fun and entertaining
aspects of that are like so important to
getting it right so you know it's
interesting because it's I mean that's
that's quite an insight I think that do
you guys kind of see yourself or do you
want to be guys who are kind of changing
the landscape and way people think about
sci-fi or you know it's put
more humor into that landscape and the
way that you guys have kind of done it
on the Internet
now moving into something that's you
know longer form but still carries a
humor
yeah well definitely I think as people
like as a younger generation that has
grown up around cameras girls older and
older they start to see the process just
a little bit more yeah within that
process is a certain sense of humor also
the more serious something gets the
easier it is to get a laugh out of
somebody you know it's that whole like
comedic relief at the end of you know
intense scene so even just us going out
and shooting something like we have to
remain aware and acknowledge when stuff
is getting too overblown or too dramatic
and you can still have a dramatic moment
you can totally make it so people can
enjoy that dramatic moment but you have
to also be able to acknowledge when
you're getting ridiculous and like when
you're going over the top are you guys
philosophical when it comes to these
things you certainly seem very
thoughtful is that the type of thing
that I mean you you have a thoughtful
approach to it is it does it define the
type of conversations you have I mean
yeah pretty much I'd say so
we try to like we don't actually have
that I mean we have enough experience
from the last few years on YouTube and
really getting our content out there
before that we'd made videos together
and we just didn't really have that big
of an audience to like discuss and get
critiques from but after doing it on
YouTube like even though we haven't
tried everything we don't actually have
experienced you know like all around the
board but um we certainly have at least
like you know you have those you get
those intuitions very quickly after
you're doing stuff and I'm sure you guys
have that too it's like what works what
doesn't work even if you haven't tried
it or you you know you you know you can
imagine it working out or not working
out and it starts to just guide you so
yeah it's just really that collection of
experiences good instinct gets you
pretty far but after you've been doing
it for a couple years and you start
having a team of people that like are
actually living off you know you're the
production company you want to start
stepping away from gut instincts and
trying to define how things are working
just a little bit more specifically well
let's go back to the beginning the
developing of those instincts I when did
you guys first meet like junior high
school yeah about we actually worked
together on the video for the first time
in nine
when we made a Star Wars fan feel about
14 years ago is that one on youtube the
Star Wars fan tonight we're uploading it
April first roll first
it's coming out whisking me up the best
thumbnail but it's gonna be a 14 year
old and we were 14 years old so by the
time this comes out it will have been
out so people will be able to watch it
yes speak freely
alright is it so is this an April Fool's
prank yeah yeah it's because it's gonna
be a people are gonna you know see our
subscription feed and they're gonna see
we upload this super-sick half hour long
Star Wars fan film and there's a
behind-the-scenes to go with it we're
gonna talk about it can the the I mean
how you go from eating to making a
half-hour Star Wars film well uh well
that's what you know ninth-grade you
know got a lot of things on your plate
really yeah that's that's really about
all I can say the Phantom Menace just
came out yeah so I was like Star Wars is
pretty cool again who's who had the
camera
Sam's a dad and my go1 had actually ran
like a online business back in the day
and like yeah Sam had all the swankiest
gear I thought they just started with
the gl2 I didn't even know about the
pretty great so what kind of effects did
you guys throw in there and how did you
achieve those frame by frame you know in
After Effects so you can like animate
things over like a few frames we didn't
we weren't even doing that for our
lasers in lightsabers I was like it was
frame by frame in Photoshop imagine
drawing a line over yours and like yeah
just like line after line after line so
I think Sam did lifesavers for a month
you know even longer than that and what
was your intention with the film at the
time do you be in Star Wars be a part of
it and yeah and we did it but 14 years
ago where who were you gonna show it to
best friends like the school news
broadcasting program or whatever George
Lucas George Lucas big hopes there's
gonna be the best our Sam film anybody's
ever seen which it wasn't
really in all seriousness like a total
of probably about 20 people have seen it
yeah well not anymore
how'd you talk about it because people
liked it I mean odd but on the internet
though it's gonna be hundreds I think
deep down inside like pardon me like I
knew I want to do film like way back
then so I think there's a part of me
that's like someday someday when like
I've made it I'm gonna put this out
there and ever he's gonna see it so a
day is whenever this comes out - however
many days it is April 1st so you've made
it is that what you're saying I mean it
because I think that's it yeah a lot of
us as we struggle to link your right
define the genre and it's you can only
say there's that next thing I want to do
as an artist or as a creator or I want
to get that many more views or
subscribers or I want to make this type
of film it's hard to know to take that
moment to take that breath and assess
and say you know that the dream that I
had as a kid I'm actually living that
now alright so you're saying you have
that realization yeah I actually had two
benchmarks for when I had made it oh wow
an actual quality at smarten final that
is large like extra huge pack of bacon I
was like when I buy that pack of bacon
I'll I've made it did you buy it
Harley Morenstein bought it when we did
our collab with every real time that
exactly like same branded packs was like
a forty dollar bacon that's not like
when a bearded belligerent Canadian yeah
except you see like I made it because we
were doing a collab with Epic Meal Time
was symbolic okay
symbolic bacon and the second one rolled
Star Wars our Star Wars fan film going
up and confusing hopefully finally
seeing it finally having what's the name
of the news audience
that's spin-off Star Wars movie oh I
know which one you're talking about yeah
that's gonna be the title of the one we
release just by Christmas
did you guys have I ask you this because
you know we've known each other forever
and had these ambitions and we would we
would have these
/ serious conversations about what we
wanted to accomplish when we grew up did
you guys have those kinds of
conversations that you kind of look back
and you're like well we were we were
dreaming we were crazy you know I mean
honestly the only conversation that we
kind of still have is like all right
what is like when are we gonna make that
huge big budget project you know
whatever that form comes in but like
even in like back in high school even
like after this stuff after finishing
the Star Wars you know project you know
that was still the thing is like man I
wonder when that's gonna happen how do
you do that like how does that even like
come into existence you know and we're
still like very close to hopefully
figuring that out but like still that's
that's that one little nagging one where
it's like how do we make something like
the stuff we saw up in that movie
theater screen or on TV or whatever you
know so like yeah I don't know what's
that do you guys do you guys have a
moment or like a benchmark at which you
considered it you made it well smart and
final across the street like this huge
thing of toilet paper in the trunk do we
do we have a benchmark like that a bacon
bench Monica yeah bacon benchmark I
think it's it's you know it's very much
a you just kind of find yourself in this
process and you're like well if I could
a year ago if I hadn't known we were
gonna be doing this I would have been
very surprised but now that we're doing
it I'm still thinking that this isn't
that cool and what are we gonna do a
year from now yeah and I kind of feel
like that's just a constant mindset that
anybody in this business who's ambitious
and who has a goal you know because when
you when you talk about that that that
thing you know that really resonates
with me that thing that seems not that
there's anything wrong or anything
we're not belittling YouTube and
having an online audience and you know
we could have we never set out to
achieve much with good mythical morning
and that's become like one of our main
things right in terms of audience not
that those things are not important but
yeah you always think but it still
doesn't feel like I've done the thing
that I respected in a certain way yeah
my entire life
yeah I feel like in a weird way like
that will almost never happen you'll
never catch it
it's never gonna you shouldn't catch it
right because if you want the moment you
do it's like oh well I'm just gonna kick
back and die now it's like yeah at that
point it's it's I don't know well then
the mediums always changing you know by
the time right
oh yeah that's if we ever get to do a
big-budget film which hopefully you know
we're on track to do like it's gonna be
very different than what big-budget
films were back when we were watching
them when we never and when he hadn't
made videos when he wanted to make them
yes Nicolas Cage he's gonna be out of
the business which you know it's a great
segue into the snapper hero thing you
guys are doing which kind of explain
really quickly for people who might not
know what what that is alright so
snapper hero is a series that is
exclusively for snapchat not snapchat
the company but literally just we're
putting it on snapchat
story-wise it's no differently than any
other half hour long series you might
watch in places but what's unique about
it is that we are telling a story about
a group of friends who discover they
have superpowers through this this
social medium snap Chandos friends are
youtubers or vibes or a snapchatters
exactly who you know in those mediums
exactly people who are already you know
very natural on that platform now we got
to take one step back though and I mean
we almost have to level set about what
is snapchat because I mean there's still
I mean when is the first time that you
personally got on snapchat and was it
when you signed on to direct snap no
this is about a Europe for me it was
about a year ago and I've been using it
and Brandon was like a snapchat and like
what snapchat it's like it's this weird
thing people send dirty pictures with
and like all right so I
get me that yeah so um we you know I'd
been like messing around with it and it
was like all right you know that's it's
like your stuff disappears on it and I
didn't really get into it too much but
um what ended up developing there's all
this disappears on it yeah you said
things and it's everything expires it is
a it is a video and then one of the
limitations of the video well basically
it's so it's started I'm still not on it
so it started out as just a messaging
app where your messages disappeared and
then eventually text text and photo or
video everything's got an expiration
timer on it you can only see it for X
amount of seconds and you can set that
yeah and you can set that and so what
they ended up integrating after that was
this thing called your story or the my
stories tab so rather than just sending
a video let's say for me to you I can
just post the video under my name and
anyone who's friends with me can watch
it it still expires though but only
after about 24 hours and an asset of a
few seconds what's the link limit and
then about 10 10 second long videos is
the max but you can put as many 10
second long videos up you can chain them
as long as you can put chain after chain
after chain of 10 second long videos but
it's a 10 second long video maximum and
do they live until a user accesses them
and then they expire that's what's
different about the stories is because
the stories are alive for 24 hours after
posting forever and you can watch them
as many times as you want
unlike the direct versions so it's you
know it's like the same equivalent of
imagine like Twitter each time you make
a tweet it's there for 24 hours and then
disappears and it's just like that
except for these little video clips so
interpersonally how would how do people
use snapchat like I was grilling Alex
and Ben who work with us on our team
because because they use it all right
well yeah you hear the thing about will
people send dirty pictures yeah but I
mean did you use it interpersonally was
basically in nikko when you when did you
start using it
well here basically it's it's it's it's
like a slower more documentary version
of vine vine is like very like heavily
edited because you have very little time
you know it's like
quick little mini scripted story haha
joke punchline the end snapchat is a
little closer to it's still in that it's
in that vein but it's not it's not so
like it's not so self-contained because
you can just keep stacking these clips
after Clips after Clips and you can make
these as long as you want so that the
stories and stuff you'll find on there
are a little more about like immersion
and seeing a location or seeing an
experience just telling a joke but
that's if you're an entertainer if
you're following an entertainer if
you're just interpersonally wanting to
snapchat with your body you just want to
see like like I don't know an orifice or
something well there's a certain
psychology about it when your messages
expire like let's save let's say you're
texting well what's so funny commuted
orifice I was like why do you say oh ffs
what's that I don't know FS man it's
good for showing orifices babies also
well so the psychology aspect real quick
so I said I text you and I want to text
you a dumb picture right well I have to
go to it to save it to send it you get
it in and it saves and it clutters up
your phone yeah you know it's like if
I'm gonna send you a picture and a text
message it better be a frickin good
picture mm-hm you know but snapchat is
all about like you know don't sweat it
it can be a picture sorry can I say yeah
yeah exactly so it's like yeah I'm just
gonna send you a casual picture whatever
who cares
and then like you're like ha that's
mildly amusing and I'm gonna send you
one back and then it just facilitates
this kind of really relaxed
communication with media and it's over
because then it's not like you're going
through your text later and you know
like I had this conversation with
somebody yeah yeah like that was boring
or pointless or I don't know I'm not
saying it was grotesque it was just
boring yeah it wasn't an orifice do
something better with your no a mess so
you're not high okay I get that so it's
just well it's you know it's it it's
just gone it's like saying something in
this out there and then it goes away
exactly extremely hurtful and then it
stays in your cycle forever it changes
who you are and yourself is your
self-worth
so how did you get involved in this in
this project well some people that have
worked with us in the past knew the
producer who was putting together the
snapchat thing and he was looking for
somebody that could direct this really
unique progressive really yeah
experimental I mean we pheromonal is the
best way to put it
we shot I won't call it progressive just
yet cuz I don't know if it's really
progressive cuz we're we've spent our
entire careers learning how to shoot
like really cool widescreen shots with
fancy lenses and then we took this
project and suddenly we were doing
running around with our phones doing
selfies something which is usually I I'm
I'm very against doing usually moralize
I'm like I'm like what am I doing with
my life
selfie yeah I think we shot more minutes
of vertical video like consecutively
than anybody else in history well you
know well we well I'm go ahead and ask
question just because you're talking
about the selfie thing I just assume
everybody was shooting themselves until
I watched the behind the scenes and I
see Harley shooting himself but he's
actually just holding your hand Nico
holding your wrist and my exactly yeah
anytime there's a tricky shot broom we
need specific angles and framing usually
our hand is they're actually holding
them okay so that was the entire process
no hardly knows how to shoot itself or
just for Harley yeah goes back to the
whole cast thing you know maybe when he
holds my wrist but yeah making sure you
know it's not just like we're not just
working with actors we're working people
who are like you know this kind of
platform in this town of media cuz it's
like alright you're the cameraman Harley
and here's the phone and we're gonna
step back and just go film the scene
yeah and yeah it's not really cool but
what's the story and how did you
incorporate audience feedback in real
time into the actual story well the
audience feedback came first actually
where they this snapper hero community
like the whole team running back kind of
put together this whole thing I'm like
here's your actors are gonna be does
anybody have any power suggestions
go through those arms so that's Harley
that's Anna who we talked to recently
just rain
Simone Shepard and Sean Doris ready up
in there to Freddie Wong yeah there's a
touch of Clinton Jones and so they they
snapchat it out I'm doing this thing
tell me what my superpower should be in
my as a character as myself in snapper
here yeah or what does my wish my
costume be etc and so we worked with
with that is a mix like there with our
own ideas with what we wanted for
certain powers and certain things but a
lot of what the fans came back with like
meshed perfectly with the story and so
we were able to kind of put it all
together into yes cohesive but the
psychology of it that you explained it
it runs contrary to everything I feel as
an artist if I'm gonna put work and time
and energy into something I don't want
it to be gone in 24 hours in the first
part is gone before that sucks that
lemon part comes out yep
so it's it's interesting how did you did
you grapple with that because a little
bit but you know the thing is when
you're watching let's say you're
chilling on YouTube right because it's
your lunch break or whatever and you
pull up of it you know looking at your
sub feed and it's like yeah that could
be a cool video I'll watch it later and
then you never watch it it adds value
yeah it's it's it to me it writes me
think I gotta get in on this because it
has a certain shelf-life yeah and I'll
be honest I need to watch it like you
it's not the series like we have like
recaps on each episode and it is
designed i mean people aren't going to
see every single clip in every single
episode so the series isn't necessarily
designed to be like oh you missed it too
bad you're screwed you're this next
episode is gonna make no sense and
you're gonna hate it you know so it is
designed to have people be able to pick
it up and we actually saw the numbers of
the the third episode we released were
higher than the first one so like more
people came in to watch that third
episode than you know and you designed
so that would work yeah pretty much
hopefully there's no comment section to
read to see if we can get we can see
like screen shots and how many people
are like saving frames in the in the
series to help
give a reference of like what people are
like so you don't even get a sense of
how many people watched it we know
numbers you get you get that raw number
mm-hmm yeah and and when is it done
when is its run the last one comes out
on a roll this conversations could it
you know people listening to this right
now in in our future their present yeah
it's already called they can't even
watch like we're talking about something
that they've missed yeah well I'm sure
somebody isn't that'll put it on YouTube
well here's the thing we have we have
ideas on how to fix that you know as
video video games by the time this has
happened there might be another home for
it but we'll see who knows but I mean
the thing at the end of the day watching
it on a phone is the way it was designed
ya know right and it is on another
platform you gotta watch it and that was
the weirdest thing you know shooting a
project vertically on phones and
everything and it's like you watch it on
a computer screen you're like this sucks
and then you watch it on your phone
you're like oh my god I feel like I'm
filming this like you feel it feels like
footage that you've just shot or it's
like it's actually happened it's amazing
you're holding your I mean you couldn't
even list on the front end of this
project the things that you think you
would learn that's that's why I'm so
pioneering about it and what's so
exciting about it yeah
how was that's amazing how was AT&T
involved basically they they funded the
project they were lighting and I think
it's kind of funny because I was like
man you know like all they're all
they're getting in all they are asking
for is pretty much you know they want to
have like you know the thanks to AT&T
you know because it's a you know it's
sponsored by them and I'm trying to
think like you know like what do
companies get out of funding projects
like this cuz I know what I'm getting
out of this I'm getting an amazing
opportunity as a filmmaker you know it's
like this is obviously like I'm happy to
do it but um but yeah it's like you know
I can see I can see why they want to do
this stuff because you know it's like
snapchat is a new platform you know it's
on their devices etc and it's like this
cool way for us to make content and then
to like you know it's like people using
like AT&T services etc it says so so it
wasn't necessarily I mean cuz AT&T
it's just a provider it doesn't have its
own phone actually have kind of had this
relationship with Samsung where they
there's like an 18 t version of the
Galaxy Note 4 what you'll see a lot of
the characters using in the PS but not
everybody we don't show any other phones
okay you don't show any other but but
yeah but all in all though like I'm
really happy with the way it worked
because they you know they were not
involved with like crazy or anything
like that
TV TV 14 is yeah it's like TV 14 and
we're like that's about it we got it
interesting about it like him I'm still
processing all this snapchat this
snapper hero specifically you know you
think about the appointment viewing it's
it's giving a new generation the
sensation of what television yes used to
be exactly yes you could if you missed
if you if you didn't make the point if
you weren't sitting in on your couch
watching it when it came on you missed
yep unless they decide to put it back on
so it's this it's like this retro kind
of yeah sensation of that adds value to
it yeah I'm not sure how how effective
it is still yet but I have because I
haven't seen like the positive aspects
of that we won't we only hear the
negative aspects like why are you
putting on snapchat i I don't have
snapchat
I don't want to sign up for just to
watch this dumb show and it's like
secretly they're like you know snapchat
free yeah but you know not everybody has
a smartphone okay yeah which I've
forgotten or maybe they're not allowed
to I mean there's so many things there's
so many things you know but at the end
of it kind of shows you like you know
also why I guess we have chosen YouTube
it's so ubiquitous and like it's such
that's why it's been the best place for
us to post most of our you know content
is just because everyone can watch
videos on YouTube right Wow
as doing this project led you to think
we as a brand corridor digital need to
get in on this snapchat game game more
directly or is it just this was a cool
project maybe we'll do something else
like this but yep uh I think it's mostly
the latter actually as more prio as more
revelation
that we should get on the Instagram game
well because the thing is like you know
it's this is like ease of communication
it's this like posting of small minor
pictures and videos like when we make a
quarter digital the video like we craft
the heck out of yeah like you know
that's a ton of work isn't that video so
what about those little simple videos
and those dumb little pictures and those
little funny moments that we have like
where do those go then sometimes they go
on our Sam and Nico channel but they're
not always right for that yeah we're
just talking about that the other day I
was like oh there's be funny video yet
I'm like I think that's a better
Instagram video what's the dynamic
between the two of you how often do you
argue like how do you what what's the
depends on how much preparation we've
done beforehand only shoot like if we're
winging it it will argue a fair amount
but what does that look like like kind
of likes it's like it's like this is a
good shot and then someone's like no
this is a better shot and I'm like I'm
not moving on until I get my shot you
know we don't have time because our the
voice is raising yeah imagine imagine
this like sometimes three or four times
louder number one rule my one rule and
it's under no circumstances is anyone
allowed to touch me while on set in all
seriousness no no bones no physical is
that a running joke I just say that book
history because it breaks them out and
then I get a laugh I think I've already
touched you I'm sorry means that I need
some attention with my hand on the
shoulder and goes what is my number one
rule but you know it's when we when we
argue it's it's a very like film centric
argument like you need to consider this
character's beat in this next scene we
need to have this and you're not getting
this shot well but I'm getting this shot
for this reason and so you're not caring
enough about the film so the the
arguments are very like moment centric
and we'll figure it out and then it's
done it's like they're not personal
arguments they're like very quick heated
like we gotta figure this out because we
don't have a lot of time and like should
we figure it out we get it and we move
on and that's when we haven't prepared
we have prepared we've gone with the
shots together there's zero arguments on
that right so but when you have those is
it the people standing around like
slowly backing away
no like sometimes right and I will argue
and I'll notice like how going it's over
shoulder when I'm like just like shaking
with anger and I realize that there's
people who are quaking it's like yeah
are just like I think when we've this is
all yeah I mean experience yeah you get
that vibe every once in a while but it's
yeah we've learned to notice it because
in the end of the day like all these
arguments are for the sake of the piece
and if the argument is making the crew
or the actors lose our focus then you're
starting to hurt the piece yeah and in
the past we sometimes we get you know
maybe a little too carried away or lose
that focus but at this point we're much
more on top of that now yeah it's okay
to have an argument it's okay to be
passionate about what you're doing
that's the thing actually we haven't
stopped arguing any more or less it's
the same as about you know a few years
ago but the only difference now is that
it's much quieter and no one knows when
it's happening here is an idea and I'm
like and then we go back out there like
all right guys it's not quite that dark
but that's you know I mean that's the
thing it's like when you when you when
you disagree you don't want like what do
you do it like I'm disagreeing it's like
everyone's like wait who's if there's
two directors here and they can't agree
then yeah who am I supposed to listen to
like yeah oh no it's like that's the
last thing you want to have happen it's
just spread that confusion out there so
like we have to contain it between
ourselves is there a division of labor
maybe not on set but over the course of
corridor digital like how do you guys
divide and conquer well I think real
quick before I move on before design
conquer we should tell you about our
wildcards tell us about the wild car we
still don't have them printed I'm gonna
go print it I'm gonna print them right
now we just have a hand signal or it's
like yugioh style so when you see this
on set that means it's a wild card so
you boys like the Boy Scouts imagine
imagine you're holding an ace between
your fingers right right okay so when
we're in an argument and we each have
one wild card per shoot
I think per day of sheer day of shooting
when you're in an argument if you
settle an argument immediately you whip
out your welcome I'm playing my wild
card if the Rays are a genius back away
and like oh it's like it's like out
there is one more rule to the wild cards
you can cancel a wild card with your
wild card we're taking this idea go for
it cancel the other wild card then how
do you decide then you're still back in
the argument and no one can ever make an
executive decision after that point and
how often does that happen
we have never cancelled out well I think
the way it works is is if you play your
wild card Nikko and then Sam plays it
back Sam wins he just that's it because
you made the decision to break it out
first that you run the risk of either
getting that your what your way or he
can override it oh that seems to make
perfect sense to my whipping out your
wild card you might risk losing it and
not getting your way but then right whoa
no that's that's too that's too deep
that's good it's just deep enough but
the wild card I mean it has a certain
element of it's interesting that you've
never double wild card it though I will
say that so it you're pointing out a
problem that's not a problem for them
yet
well if me and you both have wild cards
it'll be a problem we'll print our run
of them and we'll send you guys wild
cards yeah yeah just you got to call it
something else you'll be surprised when
Welker comes out people gasp no you
can't see it even though it's an
invisible card Oh runs offset yeah the
funny thing is things get that heated
for us like I was I'm like you know
we'll get so heated in something like
the motion of pulling out a fake card is
a total departure from the tone of the
moment it's like it's a breaking
character now I am a mine French mine
but I think I think one of the reasons
that the wild card
wouldn't always work for us is a lot of
times it's not just about two opposing
opinions it's it's like the way that
something was said it is personal it
gets personal
and then wild cards don't help when it
gets personal right and and Lync makes
it personal more than I do how long that
but so you so you need like you need
like a you need to hold up like a loofah
that needs to be well if it gets person
I hold up scissors and cut your balls
off or you can get the wild cards yeah I
do like that wild card idea yeah I mean
I'm good what I'm gonna do is I think
we're gonna make a run wild cards and
we're gonna send them to every duo
YouTube channel out there so I I would
just
I'd like to caulk us on what you call
them because it's just wild card odd
exists it's gotta be something like the
decision maker the wild cards like who
knows what it could be yeah that's rose
what's gonna happen next it's gonna be
his way but no without the wild card and
I haven't even said what I'm about to do
with it yeah it's like anything could
happen and we have to do it okay
I'm not who are we to change what's
working fabulously but I do want to eat
supper lunch I don't want to cut
anything yeah it's true actually do we
give does the producer get a well yeah
no yeah no he's no I'm with red honest I
think only the two directors get wild
comes it gets too complicated because
then how do you do the three thing
doesn't work now okay but speaking of
just you know you guys being a duo I
think a decision whether it's an
explicitly made decision or if it's just
implicit in your relationship in your
career are you guys committed to be a
creative duo indefinitely or is it just
like ah you know what I think we've got
our solo things that we want to do and I
think it's not like I've talked said
Nico give me a lot to me if we made
movies forever
I mean it's just we we take different
roles in different projects sometimes
I'm like hey I'm gonna make a video and
I go direct it and Nico helps me shoot
it and vice versa so it's like there's a
little back-and-forth there's some
things we collaborate on and some things
that
some of us take the lead on but yeah
yeah I think when it comes to you know a
creative duo you're working with the
other person because a you like your
style be you kind of just creatively
work in the same wavelength and see
usually they're very talented so for me
to not work with Sam it has to be a very
specific type of project where either
Sam's off doing something else and I you
know I just don't have you know the time
or the resources to bring him on board
or it'd be such a creative departure
that he wouldn't be able to help me with
it which would mean I'd you know we do
action we do sci-fi we do comedy we'd
like everything we do is something that
Sam is good at and generally vice-versa
for me so it has to be a huge departure
and that's fine like if you want to go
off and explore something creatively
like go for it but other than that if
there's somebody out there who I'd want
to have them help me on the project it
would be Sam you know so it's just how I
work mm-hmm so just it's sort of a it's
just kind of intrinsic to the way you
guys work yeah I mean it takes a long
time to learn to work with somebody well
creatively and really develop certain
types of skills and with our filmmaking
on YouTube we're going for this very
cinematic look but without the budget
that cinema stuff usually has so that
requires having a team of people who are
very uniquely trained I guess into doing
that and so Sam is very uniquely trained
into doing that as am i so I can't just
go out and find somebody else who can do
that you know that Sam's closest I've
you know the closest one to that I've
found and we've worked together and
we've grown the skills together so you
know it's a very much like on top of
everything else it's also a matter of
practicality like for me to go out and
shoot a project without Sam would
require a much larger budget because I'm
getting you know four people five people
to fill the role that Sam fills in a set
because he does the job with like four
to five people and yeah like I said it
also need to just be a departure from
the stuff that we'd usually do because
otherwise I would just naturally work
with him yeah I mean I like to think of
it as like a you know I'm gonna analogy
for this like a you're rolling a big
ball on a flat surface that is slowly
gathering momentum and gathering mass
and it's like you know again it gains
its own
momentum as you work longer and longer
together but it also becomes harder to
manage and they keep pushing and it's
like you get to this point where like I
I couldn't we couldn't do this old
neither of us do this alone
yeah so you you're so committed to this
thing moving forward that there's just
not really in the conversation to not
keep moving it it's out together that's
pretty much it yeah it's kind of like
well I guess I was just gonna make some
art films alone yeah that's like the
only other option right now
well pushing me pushing the ball
that's okay I'll reflect on that but you
know as an analogy yeah but you guys are
pretty good teachers don't you know
there's a lots lots to think about here
the wild card being chief among them but
uh you know I I have to say as we close
down here I learned something the first
time I talked to you guys and that it's
you spoke English I don't know what
video it was I thought you guys are like
French or something I graphic violence
or something like that there's no like
there's no talking and it was like I
think these guys are like some guys from
like Eastern Europe Freddie Moran and of
like freaking Scandinavia it doesn't
help that like for a year YouTube would
default turn on Chinese subtitles on all
our videos just like any time I just go
to computer like was just a computer I'd
never touched before and like go to our
channel like freakin Chinese about like
you couldn't change like what was by
default
we'd have fans like crowd-sourced
subtitles for us and it'd be like for
some reason is always pick some random
one like why can't just default to like
nothing but a third person to say oh you
know that's really funny no but it makes
you the first person I've heard say that
heard something else say no I haven't
what I'm saying it makes total sense I
think the first time I met you guys I
just wild by the fact that you're both
very tall in fact both you guys endemic
mealtime crew are very tall people yeah
yeah yeah what's up with that yeah
they're tall about to ambach they're
just like a crush you
well listen guys uh why don't you sign
the table we appreciate the time this is
very cool there was a near biscuit with
corridor digital of course wild card
yeah let's talk about that well first I
want to ask you guys to give them
feedback what did you think about our
conversation use hash tag ear biscuits
and tweet at them that's at corridor
digital to talk to Sam and Nico let them
know what you thought guys you can also
let us know what you thought about this
ear biscuit on iTunes by leaving a
review and a rating we appreciate that
it goes a long way you can also join in
on the conversation on soundcloud so
they said that they are going to
literally print off these cards and when
they do they said we'll get a copy man
I'm pretty pretty excited about it
because I you know our technique thus
far has been to just you know we don't
we don't make a scene out of arguing
with each other on set but sometimes it
will get into a protracted conversation
that has to like go into a corner and
the voice is raised and the facial
expressions get really intense it's just
a creative process people when you've
got too strong opinions that both may be
right but only one can be right and mine
can be more right and that's just what
happens with this this wildcard concept
I think they should just write a book
about that really yeah they could print
it on the card if it was a shorter [ __ ]
let's make it a brochure just put
instructions on the non foldable
pamphlet what why sell a book when you
can just sell the card it could be on
one of those rotating things that post
cards are on it like you know travel
shops souvenir shops the wild card now
that we should get money for that though
we just came up with that if they do
that we get 20% you guys listening you
hear that I just want the card and I
want to use it I think I would well in
it you can use it once on a shooter once
on a shootout every day I can't remember
I think you get it for the day you get
it for the day every day every day I
just I always enjoy talking to another
use mine for lunch
didn't isn't that what we said we're
just a no just Oh Wyn night window where
to go to watch yeah I would end up
blowing it on that everything I just
like talking to another creative duo
because it's so interesting to see how
you know the mechanics of it because
it's the it's the key to what we've
created obviously the fact that there's
two of us and that we bring things to
the table and we bad ideas around and
everybody's personality is different is
interesting the way that they they
talked about it and they were they kind
of you got the impression that these
guys don't argue a whole lot I don't
think these guys argue as much as we do
and then all of a sudden they bring out
the wild card and that was a wild card
for me because I was like well maybe
that's what we need like we need a wild
card but I think it should be a flag
well I don't think you should be called
a wild because it's pretty predictable I
mean once you know what it does you
think it should be a hand signal what if
it's just the bird well that's kind of
rude right all right guys thanks for
hanging out with us and the bird I flip
you the bird on set it means I get my
way
that's not gonna work laying the car
right now just asking you to move on so
you know you can count on us we'll be
here next week coming into your ear
holes
[Music]
[Music]